[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue en direct sur public
sénat voici les titres de présidentielle
la visite des manuels macron salariés de
whirlpool court circuité par marine le
pen la présidente du fn à lui a grillé
la politesse en se rendant avant lui sur
les cils damien tout sourire à la fédé
selphy avec les ouvriers
alors que l'ancien ministre de
l'économie a été sifflé à son arrivée
nicolas sarkozy votera emmanuel macron
l'ancien président l'a annoncé sur son
compte facebook pour lui l'élection de
marine le pen entraînerait des
conséquences très graves pour les
français tandis que jean luc mélenchon
ne dira pas pour qui il votera le 7 mai
dans cette campagne de
l'entre-deux-tours la bataille des
images a débuté mettant à l'épreuve les
stratégies de communication des deux
candidats emmanuel macron at il déjà
perdu une manche l'analyse et le
décryptage de christian delporte
spécialiste de la communication
politique et je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez réagir à cette émission avec le
hashtag sur twitter présidentielle à 360
tout avait été minutieusement préparée
pour la première sortie dans cet
entre-deux-tours d' emmanuel macron
depuis sa qualification pour le second
tour le candidat dans marche devait se
rendre à amiens pour y rencontrer à la
chambre de commerce des représentants de
l'usiné walpole mais c'était sans
compter la visite surprise de marine le
pen s'était fait à la manière
ce devait être une journée de campagne
classique
emmanuel macron est arrivé ce matin pour
une rencontre à la chambre de commerce
avec les syndicats de whirlpool
la direction avait refusé d'accueillir
le candidat dans marche
midi coup de théâtre marine le pen elle
arrive devant l'usiné whirlpool une
visite surprise pendant le point presse
des manuels macron et la candidate tire
à boulet rouge sur son adversaire comme
emmanuel macron venez ici et qu'il
entendait pas rencontré les salariés
qu'il entendait pas venir sur ce piquet
de grève mais qu'il allait dans un à
l'abri dans je ne sais quelle salle de
la chambre de commerce pour rencontrer
deux trois personnes triées sur le volet
eh bien j'ai trouvé que c'était une
preuve
dell monde mépris à l'égard de ce que
vivent les salariés veulent poule que
j'ai décidé de sortir de mon conseil
stratégique et de venir vous voir
emmanuel macron est pris de court
mais la réplique ne tarde pas à venir
madame le pen est donc venu amiens parce
que j'y venais bienvenue elle mais
madame le pen n'a pas compris comment
fonctionnait le pays nous n'avons
définitivement pas les mêmes ambitions
ni les mêmes projets madame le pen elle
fait elle de l'utilisation politique
puisqu'elle va arranger des militants
politiques sur un parti puis changement
de programme
emmanuel macron se rend lui aussi l
usine il parvient à prendre la parole
après avoir été chahuté pendant près de
45 minutes
je ne fais pas de promesses en l'air
monsieur moi je vous fais pas de
promesses en l'air là je dis juste ça va
durer non là le redressement de la
france
il va prendre du temps il va être
difficile mais je sais bien que je sais
bien que le combat d'ici là mais je ne
vous fais pas de promesses en l'air et
je reviendrai je reviendrai pour rendre
compte
l'exercice est rude pour emmanuel macron
mais le candidat dans marche ne se
démonte pas face aux salariés
l'épisode whirlpool marque le début
d'une campagne très dure pour le second
tour alors qu emmanuel macron a été
critiqué ces derniers jours pour son
absence sur le terrain et dans ce
contexte à les deux candidats ont
présenté leurs affiches de campagne pour
le second tour et leur nouveau slogan
pour emmanuel macron ce sera ensemble la
france pour marine le pen
choisir la france la candidate fn qui ne
cache plus tendre la main aux électeurs
de la france insoumise julien desvages
11h30 le conseil stratégique de campagne
vient tout juste de se terminer
marine le pen s'engouffre dans une
voiture personne ne sait encore quelle
prend la direction de l'usiné wire poule
damien car l'événement que tout le monde
attend ici c'est la présentation de la
nouvelle affiche et du nouveau slogan de
campagne de la candidate
c'est un projet revigorant que nous
proposons aux français et que résume
parfaitement la fiche que nous allons
vous présenter marine incarne ce choix
elle incarne le choix de la france
choisir la france voilà le slogan pour
ce second tour
par opposition choisir emmanuel macron
ce serait donc choisir l'étranger c'est
le message que les lieutenants de marine
le pen ont martelé ce slogan résume bien
notre notre projet choisir la france
face à un candidat monsieur m'a conquis
le choisir l'oligarchie qui choisit le
mondialisme qui choisit de l'union
européenne mais jamais la france sur
cette affiche marine le pen dévoile sa
féminité
la bibliothèque elle rappelle certains
portraits officiels de président de la
république
autre détail important seul le prénom de
la candidate reste aucune référence au
nom de famille le pen
le front national continue dans sa
stratégie de rassemblement en ciblant
notamment les électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon chez monsieur mélenchon il ya
des électeurs aujourd'hui qu'ils ne
souhaitent pas que le candidat du
système quand il ya des finances
candidat du medef le candidat des
banques soit leur président de la
république et qui vont porter leur voix
et leur soutien nous le savons parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous voyons bien dans les
mails dans les témoignages que nous
recevons il y a un vrai réservoir
électoral chez plusieurs candidats aller
chercher des voix donc une stratégie
résolument offensif de la part de marine
le pen dans cette bataille de
communication depuis le soir du premier
tour la candidate du front national ne
cesse de marquer des points
je vous le disais en titre nicolas
sarkozy dans un message facebook appelle
clairement à voter en faveur du candidat
dans marche alors que jean luc mélenchon
refuse de dire pour qui il votera au
second tour du côté des militants de la
france un soumise à la consultation a
commencé
mounir souci est juline lever les
interrogations et clarifier la position
de la france insoumise pour le second
tour deux missions délicates pour les
cadres du mouvement
jean luc mélenchon a refusé de donner
une consigne de vote au soir du premier
tour et son équipe assurent qu'il
gardera aussi le silence sur son choix
personnel
jean luc mélenchon aura sa décision et
son choix personnel gardera sans doute
pour lui et ensuite il ya une dimension
politique et la dimension politique elle
est réglée par la publication des
résultats de la consultation que nous
organisons le principe de cette
consultation proposée au 450 mille
personnes inscrites sur le site de la
france insoumise était annoncée bien
avant le premier tour trois options sont
aujourd'hui proposés le vote blanc ou
nul
le vote pour emmanuel macron où
l'abstention le vote pour marine le pen
n'est pas envisagée
critiqué pour son refus d'appeler
officiellement à voter pour emmanuel
macron la garde rapprochée de jean luc
mélenchon rejette les procès d'intention
et enrage que l'on puisse comparer leur
mouvement à celui de marine le pen aux
idéaux pleure aussi des examens de
conscience c'est pas moi qui mets front
national au deuxième tour
c'est pas moi qui le fais et je dois
dire que je suis prêt à discuter
beaucoup de gens mais mais pas ça mais à
l inverse se répète fait passer le
message ça n'est pas un ni ni
c'est pas marqueront le pen égale macro
égale le pen c'est pas ça notre
d'ailleurs dans les options vous le
voyez quart monde et je le dis
clairement vous l'avez vu dans le texte
que nous présentons il ne faut pas voter
front national il ne faut pas les
résultats de la consultation seront
publiés mardi 2 mai des chiffres qui
pourraient éclairer les sept millions
d'électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
aujourd'hui très divisé et florian
philippot vice-président du front
national était l'invité de notre
émission à l'épreuve de vérité il réagit
à cette double visite des manuels macro
et de marine le pen a bien écouté il a
et soutient le ligue archi mais d'après
les images qu'on a vue d'ouvrir le plus
il n'a pas lé soutien de la population
et elle et ça je crois que ça devrait
inquiéter
moi ça me surprend pas que j'ai vu le
président de la commission européenne
j'ai vu liu wei f les islamistes de
l'oeil elle a appris à voter pour lui
j'ai vu hani ramadan qui était viré de
france et quelques jours passés pour
radicalisation islamiste voulait dire
qu'aussi j'ai vu monsieur j'ai vu le ps
veut hollande j'ai vu valls qui a dit
qu'il voulait faire partie de son
gouvernement
tout cela j'ai vu madame parisot qui
quémandent déjà un terroriste oblique à
l'ancienne du medef des républiques j'ai
vu des républicains pas tous mais j'en
ai vu effectivement non mais quand je
dirais pu dire tout ça de même sens
large
non mais républicain l'est républicain
ça m'étonne pas c'est toute la ligue
archi qui se coalisent autour de sa
candidature et de son candidat c'est
tout et ça c'est la preuve qu'il est un
candidat coupé de la réalité c'est le
candidat le liage où vous résumer en
défend la politique
résumé l'opinion publique à l'événement
on sera là remonte à damien philippot
nous avons dit poindre montada à faire
et on va la faire joyeusement en une
dizaine de jours forte hausse du chômage
en mars +1 3% cela représente 43 mille
700 demandeurs d'emploi supplémentaires
à noter que cela constitue cependant une
baisse sur un an de -0 9% et justement
j'accueille au thème traduit bonsoir
table avec vous on va voir les
programmes économiques des candidats et
notamment les objectifs de marine le pen
et d'emmanuel macron en matière de lutte
contre le chômage de masse
oui alors on découvre d'ailleurs sur
leur objectif est bien que marine le pen
a beau régulièrement tonné contre le
nombre de chômeurs d'air qu'elle exagère
toujours hier encore sur le plateau de
tf1 à l'appareil de 7 millions de
chômeurs alors qu'on est au maximum si
on comptabilise
les trois premières catégories à 5
millions et demi donc à la bo exagérer
les statistiques
elle ne donne aucun objectif chiffré
pour son quinquennat si elle était élue
en matière de réduction du nombre de
chômeurs en revanche emmanuel macron lui
veut revenir à un taux de 7 % de
chômeurs horizon 2022 contre 10 %
aujourd'hui
concrètement quelles sont les
propositions de marine le pen pour
réduire le chômage tam et bien marine le
pen elle ne parle jamais de chômeurs
dans son programme
pas une seule fois le terme est utilisé
parmi les 144 proposition j'ai vérifié
la candidate du front national n'a donc
pas une seule mesure pour réformer
l'assurance chômage qui est très
déficitaire ou encore sur les
indemnisations
donc ces propositions ne concerne que
l'emploi et oui effectivement et
d'ailleurs pour s est assez simple c'est
toujours la même recette choisir la
france au lieu de l'étranger déjà le
cadrage général pour marine le pen et
bien il faut sortir de l'union
européenne revenir au franc ce qui
serait synonyme de crise politique de
crise économique est nécessairement il y
aurait un impact sur l'emploi
par ailleurs pour lutter contre le
chômage de masse marine le pen propose
la priorité nationale pour l'emploi qui
passe par une taxe sur l'embauché des
salariés étrangers y compris ceux
l'union européenne ce qui change par
rapport à la situation actuelle
elle propose aussi de fusionner le cic
avec les allègements de charges
un dispositif qui serait conditionnée au
maintien de l'emploi sous peine de
remboursement par l'entreprise et qu'en
est il pour emmanuel macron tan dung lui
compte sur son programme économique qui
permet de libérer les entreprises de
leurs entraves pour renouer avec la
croissance et l'emploi
il propose donc des allègements de
charges pour les entreprises
l'investissement également dans la
formation il y en a beaucoup parlé avec
lui aujourd'hui
et puis également il propose des
protections mais au niveau européen et
pas au niveau national mais lui propose
une réforme de l'assurance chômage
oui et c'est là la grande différence est
qu'il propose une réforme extrêmement
ambitieuse de l'assurance chômage avec
d'abord une reprise en main par l'état
alors qu'aujourd'hui l'assurance chômage
est entre les mains des partenaires
sociaux à travers l'unedic
il met également en place un système de
bonus malus pour pénaliser les
entreprises qui ont le plus recours aux
cdd
également il est temps l'assurance
chômage à tous les travailleurs c'est là
une des grandes mesures
universalité de l'assurance chômage donc
aux indépendants au mais aussi aux
personnes qui démissionne dans une
limite d'une fois tous les cinq ans ce
qui d'ailleurs pourrait coûter au
passage très cher en contrepartie et
bien emmanuel macron contrôler davantage
les chômeurs ils mettent en place des
sanctions plus sévères toute personne
qui on a refusé deux emplois décents et
bien se verra ses allocations chômage
suspendu et puis enfin niveau
financement
il préconise une augmentation de la csg
ce qui veut dire que tous les français
paierait pour l'assurance chômage au
lieu de seuls les salariés aujourd'hui
en résumé donc marine le pen n'a pas
d'objectif chiffré de réduction du
chômage ni de propositions de réforme de
l'assurance chômage mais une réforme de
l'emploi qui se résume en un mot la
priorité pour les français emmanuel
macron lui a un objectif 7 % de chômeurs
en 2022 ce qui est très ambitieux tout
comme sa réforme dont la mise en oeuvre
est une véritable révolution et dont le
chiffrage peut inquiéter
merci beaucoup et âme pour tout vos pr
précision la bataille à des images a
commencé entre les deux finalistes est
pour l'instant marine le pen semble
avoir un temps d'avancé à la candidate
fn occupe le terrain tandis qu emmanuel
macron multiplient né faut pas sandra
cerqueira un discours jugé décevant
une fête controversée à la rotonde
depuis sa qualification au second tour
emmanuel macron doit répondre aux
critiques sur son attitude dimanche soir
et sur sa discrétion
alors qu'il consulte en vue d'une future
majorité donnant l'impression d'enjamber
le second tour marine le pen elle est
omniprésente sur le terrain excès de
confiance ou erreur de communication
emmanuel macron ne repart en campagne
qu'aujourd'hui après un passage sur
france 2 où il est apparu le visage
beaucoup plus sévères et combatif
contrastant avec celui de dimanche soir
j'assume totalement et j'assumerai
toujours ce ne sera pas le diktat d'une
bien pensants ce triste qui me dira où
je dois aller
l'objectif maintenant pour lui rattrapé
les deux jours perdus où il va pour cela
multiplié les déplacements sur des
terres favorables au fn hier soir sur
tf1 marine le pen elle est apparue
souriante jouant la carte de la sérénité
et même la mère de famille qui cherche à
rassembler crois sincèrement que le
projet de monsieur macro est ultra
minoritaire il veut vraiment la france ô
is là pour le coup il pourrait récupérer
peut-être ceux des slogans détournés de
mélangeant selon un sondage harris
interactive 61% des français pensent que
marine le pen a mieux réussi le début de
la campagne du second tour et mon invité
ce soir christian delporte êtes
historien spécialiste des médias et de
la communication politique
la journée aura été marquée par cette
séquence incroyable qui s'est déroulée
en direct sur les écrans à des chaînes
d'info de marine le pen qui a court
circuité la visite d' emmanuel macron a
bien suivi dans l'après-midi de
l'arrivée en direct du candidat dans
marche sur le site de ouerdes poule
alors est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un selon
vous qui sort vainqueur ou peut-être
perdant de ce duel médiatique vous
lisiez tout à l'heure c'est une bataille
d'image et d'une certaine manière la
campagne électorale du deuxième tour
commence aujourd'hui à travers ces
images on peut dire que la matinée a été
favorable à marine le pen dans la mesure
où elle a occupé ce terrain de l'image
d'abord parce qu'elle comprend très bien
comment fonctionne la télévision et
qu'elle a fait un coup de com ce ya pas
de coude comme si les médias ne le
relais pas parce qu'au fond elle est
arrivée là fait une déclaration la fédé
selphy et là elle a promis quelque chose
mais qu'elle sauverait 7,7 cuisine mais
on lui signe un chèque en blanc mais
néanmoins cette première phase lui a été
favorable
la deuxième at elle été favorable le
maquereau c'est comme dans un film
il ya une intrigue ça commence parfois
très mal et puis ça peut se terminer
très bien aussi
ça a duré une heure et demi c'est long
une heure et demie marine le pen était
venu 25 minutes et au départ ça se passe
plutôt mal et on a saisi il est sifflé
il est hué mais il reste qu'elle ne s'en
va pas et ils cherchent dialogue et au
bout du compte on a cette image assez
étonnante à la fin où il serre des mains
alors qu'est ce qu'on va retenir qu'est
ce que les télévisions vous retenir le
vacarme du début où le fait qu'il soit
resté pendant 1h30 en parlant
effectivement comme il le dit avec
responsabilité
ça c'est la suite des choses chez nous
il ya un effet on a beaucoup critiqué le
retard à l'allumage en quelque sorte d'
emmanuel macron dans cette campagne
d'entre deux tours est ce qu'avec cette
séquence ce retard et effacer ce qui
peut encore rattraper ce retard par
rapport à une candidate on l'a vu très
habitué des déplacements sur le terrain
c'est encore long la campagne électorale
du deuxième tour il ya encore d'autres
étapes et on voit que tous les jours
fait long il va se passer quelque chose
néanmoins je pense que emmanuel macron
là est vraiment entré dans une campagne
où seule marine le pen était entré
jusqu'à présent et c'est dans ce genre
de confrontation de terrain que se
révèle d des candidats et des
présidentiables donc d'une certaine
manière on ne va plus parler de la
rotonde et du design des tournées avant
que la page est tournée
on va parler de ça est ce qu'il en sera
bénéficiaire ou pas
c'est encore difficile de le savoir
aujourd'hui on entendait emmanuel macron
dire qu'il refusait et bien que sont le
propre rythme lui soit imposé par les
médias ça c'est une erreur de stratégie
de compréhension justement du rythme et
au contraire qui est imposé par les
médias dans cette campagne
alors pour ne pas être marquée par le
rythme médiatique
il faut s'appeler françois mitterrand
donc c'est effectivement ce qu'il avait
fait dans la campagne de 1988 et on
disait à l'époque combien les silences
du mitterrand était du génie politique
on n'est plus dans cette période là les
candidats ne sont semble plus à hauteur
de françois mitterrand mais bien sûr
qu'on campagne électorale elle se fait
au rythme médiatique et donc
on va le voir dans les jours qui
viennent ne serait-ce que ce soir à
travers à travers le meeting d'amiens
pour pour emmanuel cros un meeting c'est
d'abord sert pour les médias d'abord
faire dix marchés d'abord fait pour la
télévision
justement sur ce choix des manuels macro
de cibler les régions justement où le
front national a fait un bon score est
ce que c'était un choix risqué et est-ce
qu'il est en terrain miné ce qui ne
risque pas justement d'être confronté se
voir talonné à chaque déplacement par
marine le pen peut-être pas de cette
façon là mais je pense qu'il a acquis la
raison d'aller dans les régions qui ne
lui sont pas favorables puisque en fait
toute la démonstration que le monde
d'ailleurs les cartes électorales c'est
qu'il y à une france qui a voté le pen
et l'autre qui avait été m'accrocher
voilà la france des déshérités a plutôt
voté l'open donc il a en termes de
communication tout à fait raison d'aller
sur ces terrains dans le monde ouvrier
dans le monde rural ne serait ce que
pour affirmer son courage politique dans
cette campagne d'entre deux tours on a
vu aujourd'hui les nouvelles affiches
avec les nouveaux slogans à des deux
candidats ensemble la france pour
emmanuel macron choisir la france pour
marine le pen cas lecture faites vous de
ces deux affiches dans le cadre des
manuels macro on a à se manquer quand
même pas très très original c'est
classique
qui a fait d'un déjà été pris il n'y a
pas assez longtemps par jacques chirac
en 2002 ou au nicolas sarkozy en 2007
il y a la volonté de marquer
rassemblement de marquer ma retraite
traditionnelle et crédibilité
présidentielle
la fiche de marine le pen d'ailleurs a
été plus comme vanter parce qu'elle est
beaucoup plus surprenante
on a là l'image d'une femme politique
qui est un petit peu au working girl une
certaine décontraction marqué par le
fait qu'elle soit assise en partie est
sûre sur ses tables mais derrière il y à
l'arrière fond prévisions incidentielle
cette bibliothèque que nous avons
tellement vu avec de gaulle pompidou
mitterrand clé press et ça effectivement
on voit qu'il ya cette dimension elle
veut se présidentialiser à ce qu'elle y
est parvenue selon vous à travers cette
affiche est à travers aussi sa campagne
elles sont parfois ce qui est sûr en
tout cas c'est que c'est une une
campagne autour d'elle très personnalisé
une campagne électorale présidentielle
c'est d'abord la personnalisation c'est
d'abord l'affirmation des personnalités
et de ce point de vue c'est une
stratégie qu'elle a établies depuis son
arrivée au front national ne serait ce
que à travers le prénom qui finalement
efface le nom son père marine et elle y
est plutôt bien par minute
on voyait se coupent comme aujourd'hui
comme vous l'avez décrit avec cette
visite surprise amiens de marine le pen
quelles sont ses limites dans sa
stratégie de communication et dans sa
stratégie de campagne sur le terrain
dans cet entre deux tours
le problème c'est que un coup de com
c'est un c'est à fuser un coup on peut
pas faire le même coup de com tout le
temps donc il va falloir inventer une
autre chose en plus elle ne peut pas non
plus
je suivre en permanence ce que va faire
emmanuel macron parce que c'est assez
risqué ou c'est celui qui s'impose dans
une campagne électorale c'est celui qui
appose c'était mais au-delà de ces
thèmes qui s'impose lui même donc il va
falloir tout n'est qu'elle invente autre
chose on sait que le new york times
aujourd'hui à appeler emmanuel le
maquereau à retenir aussi les leçons je
signe d'arrogance mortifère de la
campagne clinton est-ce qu'on est un peu
dans la même situation que ce qui s'est
passé aux états unis christian delporte
ça n'est pas impossible
ça n'est pas impossible vous savez pour
l'instant on est dans des besoins une
fourchette de 60 40 il n'est pas
impossible que tout ça se resserre n'est
pas impossible que l'attention soit
forte
donc il faut où il faut pas se laisser
abuser par des sondages trop favorable
ce sont les français qui décide au bout
du compte et en deux semaines il peut se
passer beaucoup de choses
il y aura ce temps fort dans cette
campagne ce débat télévisé entre les
deux candidats c'est prévu le 3 mai
quels sont les avantages dans cet
exercice et les points faibles de chaque
candidat d'abord de mémoire aucun débat
si peu de temps de du deuxième tour n'a
changé véritablement les choses d'une
manière générale les électorats sont
déjà bien cristalliser les choix sont
sûres et ça change pas grand chose
alors évidemment ce que l'on dit
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a une marine le
pen qui est une grande oratrice qui a
une expérience politique et qui pourra
peut-être aurait l avantage est que dans
ce type d'exercice très outsiders serait
emmanuel macron et on a vu finalement
que
dans les débats précédant la différence
n'était pas aussi forte qu'on pouvait le
supposer
et puis vous savez en 1960 pourquoi
kennedy a gagné on a dit cook et
l'ailier avait gagné le débat pas parce
que franchement il l'avait gagnée mais
parce qu'il était là outsiders et qu'il
avait résisté à nixon donc vous et c'est
une alchimie complète et bien merci
beaucoup à christian delporte pour votre
éclairage dans le reste de l'actualité
est bien c'est la pression que mais
l'union européenne sur le premier
ministre hongrois viktor orban
il s'est exprimé cet après-midi devant
les eurodéputés à bruxelles alors avant
de retrouver notre journaliste sur place
n'aura m'a dit écoutez bien la réaction
de guy verhofstadt ancien premier
ministre belge qui sont épris à viktor
orban dans l' écoute vous avez harceler
les ong chasser les médias critiques
vous avez construit des murs vous avez
également tenter de restaurer la peine
de mort même si ce n'est pas pour nous
décider de fermer une université et ma
question est la suivante jusqu'où aller
vous allez c'est quoi la prochaine fois
la prochains jours vous allez brûler des
livres de l'autodafé devant le parlement
hongrie
le coach du rcs à la prochaine démarche
tout de suite retrouvé un omar hamadi en
direct de bruxelles bonsoir n'aura vous
avez suivi pour nous cette intervention
de viktor orban
on sait que la situation en hongrie et
provoque une inquiétude générale a lâché
aléas dirigeants européens alors qu'avez
vous retenu de cette intervention cet
après midi écoutez delphine 1 ce n'est
pas la première fois que viktor orban ne
vient au parlement européen s'adresser
aux parlementaires notamment pour
défendre sa politique est comme
d'habitude et on l'a entendu dans les
mots très durs de guy verhofstadt ce fut
un face à face extrêmement tendue guy
verhofstadt d'ailleurs qui a comparé
viktor orban nains emmanuel macron
hongrois à l'époque où il avait commencé
la politique dans les années 90 à la
chute du bloc communiste
inutile de vous dire que cet après midi
ce fut surtout le procès de l'union
européenne et la campagne présidentielle
française s'est largement invitée dans
les débats
mais ce fut donc un débat de bout en
bout face à un viktor orban inflexible
qui a conduit en fait les parlementaires
à essayer d'obtenir des explications
mais celui ci a été droit dans ses
bottes la loi qui prévoit la fermeture
de l'université centrale financée par le
milliardaire américano-hongrois george
soros est selon lui une nécessité face
aux infiltrations étrangères une forme
de nationalisme culturel la consultation
envoyé à tous ses concitoyens intitulée
stop bruxelles c'est surtout pour lui un
bon levier pour réformer l'union
européenne et pour redonner la confiance
aux peuples inflexible face aux attaques
il a ensuite comparé l'union européenne
qui viendrait potentiellement atteindre
la souveraineté nationale de la hongrie
à l'union soviétique
nigel farrage le leader du camp du break
site s'est lui aussi attaqué à la
position du premier ministre on en lui
disant vous manqué de courage
vous devriez à ce moment et bien
convoquer un référendum pour sortir la
hongrie de l'union européenne pour vous
débarrasser des fanatiques de la
commission européenne qui on le voit
bien prennent position face à marine le
pen pour emmanuel macron dans la
campagne présidentielle française
de toute façon une procédure
d'infraction a été officiellement
ouverte aujourd'hui un courrier a été
envoyé à varsovie pour obtenir des
explications
à deux jours d'un sommet sur le break
site est en pleine campagne
présidentielle c'est aussi un
signal qui a été envoyé aux électeurs
français merci beaucoup à nos reins pour
ces précisions c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à vous de m'avoir suivi
tout de suite l'épreuve de vérité
spécial présidentiel invité ce soir le
vice président du fn florian philippot
bonne soirée à demain 18h
[Musique]